[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis wels
in meinem heutigen video geht es darum
wie man lebensmittel haltbar machen kann
meine mama hat mir beigebracht immer
einen gesunden vorrat an lebensmitteln
dazu haben denn ich kann zum beispiel
immer kochen und backen eine frau aus
dem stegreif ich muss nicht extra
einkaufen gehen und gesunden
lebensmittel vorrat dazu haben ist auch
wirklich gut vor allem ist es gut wenn
man ihn da hat für die nächsten 14 tage
eben für die personen die bei euch im
haushalt leben ich kann auch immer
spontan gäste empfangen ich kann immer
spontanen kuchen backen und ich muss vor
allem nicht so oft einkaufen gehen wenn
ich so nehme ich meinen einkauf plane
meinen vorrat plane so dass ich immer
alles da habe und ich denke jeder hat
platz genug um zu sagen ich habe einen
kleinen vorrat für mich sei es im
kühlschrank oder in den vorratsschrank
oder eben auch in der history kultur
heute zeige ich euch wie ihr
lebensmittel haltbar machen könnt vor
allem wie ihr lebensmittel die ihr ein
gekauft habt richtig lagert damit sie
eben auch nicht so schnell schlecht
werden und wie es eben für eine gewisse
zeit haltbar machen könnte da gibt es
verschiedene techniken die sind auch
schon teilweise jahrhunderte alt und die
werden wir heute alle einzeln durchgehen
schlaue leute sagen ja dass man ohne
essen bis zu drei bis vier wochen
aushalten kann ohne trinken aber nur
drei bis vier tage
deswegen sollte man auch einen
wasservorrat da haben wir hier zu hause
in baku sind wir trinken leitungswasser
wir haben nämlich auch eine
enthärtungsanlage also eine wc-anlage
die löst einfach den kalk von hannover
und da können wir unser leitungswasser
nämlich schön kalt frei auch trinken
aber wir haben auch über sprudelwasser
da also was haben mit kohlensäure und
ihr solltet immer einen vorrat am wasser
auch für die nächsten zwei wochen da
haben da rechnet man einfach pro person
zwei liter am tag
also wenn bis 14 liter in der woche pro
person die ihr daneben rechnen müsse
wenn ihr ein haushalt seit mit tieren
solltet ihr auch an den tier vorrat
denken denn auch die tiere soll dich
hungern und vor allem könnt ihr euch da
viele kosten sparen weil oft große
portionen im angebot sind und ihr habt
eben immer was da und möchte ich so oft
einkaufen gehen soviel dazu und jetzt
kommen wir zum lebensmittel vorrat wenn
man sich frühere zeiten
anschaut dann ist die menschen geschafft
lebensmittel länger haltbar zu machen
obwohl sie keinen strom hatten keinen
kühlschrank und kein gefrierschrank da
gab es zum einen die methode des seins
das gemüse mit essig einzulegen
meine mama macht es auch regelmäßig ich
denke in unserem spätsommer darlegt sie
rotkohl ein bohnen gurken tomaten alles
kommt in so große fässer es kommt
essigwasser dazu und dann dauert ein
paar wochen bis das gemüse eingelegt ist
und dann hat sich wirklich schon haltbar
gemacht ich persönlich habe mich da noch
nicht herangewagt vielleicht mache ich
das dieses jahr mal aber auch ich habe
natürlich im vorrat gemüse was wirklich
sauer eingelegt wurde wie zum beispiel
sauerkraut gurken oder auch peperoni und
die habe ich dann da und die sind auch
wenn sie angebrochen sind einfach etwas
länger haltbar und damit kann man dann
leckere salate machen in gerichte mit
ein kochen oder auch tour wie antipasti
zum beispiel verzehren
eine weitere alte technik ist das
räuchern von fleisch und fisch viele
besitzen auch einen räucherofen früher
hat man das wirklich auch ganz oft zu
hause gemacht mittlerweile bekommt man
die produkte natürlich auch in jedem
supermarkt und auch da es so dass diese
lebensmittel einfach etwas länger
haltbar sind als zum beispiel frisches
fleisch oder frischer fisch das einlegen
ist auch eine altbewährte methode um
lebensmittel länger haltbar zu machen
das einlegen bewegt nämlich dass kein
sauerstoff an lebensmittel kommt und die
eben dann nicht oxidieren und dann nicht
schlecht werden einlegen kann man zum
einen in öl zum beispiel so mach ich es
gerne mit getrockneten tomaten die gibt
es ja auch schon in öl zu kaufen selbst
gemacht das pesto oder ihr könnt zb
einlegen in salzlake das mache ich auch
nicht selber sondern kauft zum beispiel
den käse eingelegt in salzlake zum
einlegen gehört zum beispiel auch dass
man käse in öl einlegen kann
und eben auch mit frischen kräutern oder
knoblauch verfeinern kann
dafür schneiden oder schafskäse in feine
würfel
die gehackte kräuter knoblauch und
pfeffer dazu und für das gefäß soweit
mit öl auf bis alle lebensmittel bedeckt
sind und somit kein sauerstoff mehr dran
kommt
[Musik]
einlegen kann man aber auch in alkohol
viele kennen vielleicht den rumtopf von
der oma noch ich weiß nicht ob es
heutzutage noch praktiziert wird ob ihr
das auch kennt von eurer oma ich kenne
es nicht weil ich meine oma hatte den
rumtopf hatte aber einlegen kann man zum
beispiel früchte ihn herum
da gibt es dann den rumtopf und dann
wird im mai begonnen habe ich jetzt nach
gelesen da kommt dann die erste frucht
rein das in erdbeeren die zweite schicht
sind dann zum beispiel ab kursen oder
pfirsiche und so könnt ihr dann von mai
bis september oktober sogar früchte
einlegen in den großen rumtopf da kommen
doch noch zucker mit dazu und dann zieht
das ganze durch und man hat soeben
bewegt dass man praktisch sommerfrüchte
auch im winter verzehren kann also
anfang dezember ist dann alles
durchgezogen und dann so wird man das
als kompott zu heiß oder zu waffeln oder
auch so einen käsekuchen und hat eben im
winter auch frische früchte aber eben
eingelegt aus dem sommer und so kann man
eben die lebensmittel auch haltbar
machen und vor allem gerade hier bei dem
eingelegten gemüse oder auch beim pesto
mit öl ist es so dass ich hier zum einen
die tomaten verwendet die ich eingelegt
habe aber eben auch das öl weil jetzt
auch der volle geschmack der tomaten zb
mit drin steckt salz ist hygroskopisch
entzieht lebensmitteln also die
feuchtigkeit und nimmt so
mikroorganismen die grundlage sich zu
vermehren
das heißt lebensmittel werden auch
dadurch nicht schlecht lebensmittel kam
mit salz auch haltbar machen hat man
auch früher schon gemacht vor allem mit
fleisch und fisch aber auch in der
afrikanischen und marokkanischen küche
gibt's zum beispiel salz zitronen die
eben also einfach zu drohnen in salz
eingelegt werden und die man dann zum
verfeinern und zum würzen von gerichten
verwendet ich hab jetzt selber noch
nichts mit salz eingelegt vielleicht
gibt's ja auch jemand von euch da sagt
hey ich hab schon seit zu tun gemacht
dann schreib doch gerne mal in die
kommentare was er damit macht also wie
man es weiter verwendet und vielleicht
können wir das ja auch mal in unser
rezept sortiment mit aufnehmen wenn ihr
euch eine lebensmittel fahrrad zulegt
ist natürlich auch wichtig dass ihr die
lebensmittel richtig lagert damit sie so
lange wie möglich halten und eben nicht
verderben
da gehört der kühlschrank auf jeden fall
mit dazu wenn ihr nach dem einkaufen
nach hause kommt wirklich immer alles
schön sofort in den kühlschrank
einräumen und da aber auch richtig
einräumen denn jeder kühlschrank hat
zone und ist es kälter als oben und so
hat jedes lebensmittel seinen perfekten
platz im kühlschrank damit eben auch die
perfekte temperatur abbekommt das zeige
ich euch in diesem video nicht dazu gibt
es nämlich schon ein ausführliches video
wo ich anschauen könnt wie man den
kühlschrank richtig einräumt eine
methode lebensmittel haltbar zu machen
ist das denn beziehungsweise trocknen
entweder macht geht es mit dem backofen
oder mit hilfe eines der automaten und
ich mach das jetzt so ich habe jetzt
hier obst und gemüse jetzt erst mal obst
denn obst chips essen wir ganz gerne als
snack das ist immer praktisch wenn man
unterwegs ist dann habe ich sie in der
handtasche die kinder nehmen es gerne
mit oder einfach so wenn wir abends auf
dem sofa sitzen und vor allem kann ich
so obst und gemüse auch retten was sonst
vielleicht verschimmeln würde weil es
einfach schon ewig lange herum steht und
wenn jetzt gerade nicht lust auf
smoothies haben oder auch fruchteis dann
wird es eben kurz gedauert wird so
länger haltbar gemacht es kann nicht
mehr kaputt gehen und wir haben einfach
immer was auf vorrat ich habe jetzt hier
einfach schon mal ein paar äpfel und
birnen eine ananas habe ich auch schon
eine mango geschenk gleich hole ich noch
gemüse mit dazu und im prinzip ist beim
darin einfach nur wichtig dass obst und
gemüse ganz dünn zu schneiden oder dünn
zu hobeln damit eben auch gleichmäßig
und schnell trocknet also ich zeig euch
das jetzt mal hier mit den äpfeln
die habe ich jetzt gewaschen schon die
entkernt kurz die schade lasse ich dran
unter der schale sitzen ja sowieso meist
die wertvollen nährstoffe und entweder
können das jetzt hier hobeln dazu mit so
einer ganz normalen hubl oder ihr könnt
doch ein sparschäler verwenden weil es
war im april ein bisschen schwierig bei
der man guckt etwas einfacher ich zeige
euch das jetzt mal hier schön dünn sind
dann habt ihr diese apfelringe und hier
muss sich jetzt den finger schutz nehmen
aber wenn der apfel zu groß ist genau
dann geht es gar nicht bei größeren
leben tatsächlich kann sich jetzt ein
apfel auch halbieren und dann einfach
weiter hobeln und bei größeren
lebensmitteln da eignet sich ganz guten
alles schneider oder einfach eine
größere hobel
hab da keine probleme damit habe ich
jetzt hier keine ab geringe sondern
apfel monde
wenn ihr aber sowieso viel machen
möchtet unten alles schneider habt könnt
ihr das auch wirklich schon immer alles
schneider machen
da kann ich nämlich ganz viel eine ganz
große menge aufzubereiten und eben auch
ziemlich schnell und gleichmäßig ich
werde sie auch gleich die äpfel in
wasser legen mit etwas zitronensaft
damit sie beim darin nicht braun werden
also hier einfach eine große schale mit
wasser bisschen zitrone rhein und die
äpfel dazu und in der zeit kann ich die
übrigen äpfel auch schon seit
feinschneiden und beim apfel können die
das kerngehäuse entfernen oder auch
einfach dran lassen
[Musik]
da ich hier noch meine perlen scheiben
apfelscheiben schlägt jetzt auch schon
mal auf meinen automaten
denn ich muss gucken wie viel platz sich
dann noch habe und ob die anderen das
heute noch drauf passt oder er morgen
habe cd apple noch mal ein bisschen
abtrocknen lassen und abtropfen lassen
damit die feuchtigkeit schon mal nicht
entzogen werden muss
ich packe jetzt hier direkt auf die
bleche ich mache es jetzt im tor
automaten den kann ich nämlich einfach
den ganzen tag laufen lassen und
blockierer in backöfen nicht im backofen
könnt ihr auch dahin aber ihr habt doch
nicht so viele einschub höhen wie in
einem dörr tomaten und vor allem müsste
dann wirklich ein backofen acht bis zehn
stunden laufen lassen bei umluft damit
überhaupt haben das oft und gemüse gibt
dort werden kann
also wenn ihr öfter hört dann finde ich
und der automaten wirklich ideal weil
man das wirklich in jedem tag nebenher
machen kann und dann hat man auch
wirklich immer wieder im gebrauch ich
lege es jetzt hier auf die einzelnen
fächer darauf kann auch dann ganz
präzise bei ganz wenig dem motto darin
so bleiben die vitamine auch schön
erhalten und alles was jetzt noch so
mega klein ist nehme ich jetzt zur seite
daraus mache ich nämlich gleich zwei
päckchen also die schmeiße ich nicht weg
perfekt ich habe noch platz für mango
hier habe ich jetzt meine mango mit der
manko funktioniert am besten wenn man
sie schält und dann am bauhof direkt
fein hobeln
[Musik]
und hier beim drauflegen einfach nur
darauf achten dass sich das obst nicht
berührt haben jetzt eben nicht zusammen
und lebt
[Musik]
das habe ich hier alle sechs blech hier
drin ich habe ich noch ananas übrig und
wohl noch anderes obst denn ich hab ein
zweiter automaten wie gesagt könnt ihr
sie mit der automaten darin und trocknen
oder im backofen im backofen dann auch
bei maximal 50 grad
hier kann ich die temperatur auch noch
ganz präzise einstellen
manche dinge die trocknet auch nur bei
40 grad oder bei 35 und im backofen je
nachdem was für modell ihr habt ist hat
auch nicht so energieeffizient also da
musst du einfach mal schauen
ich stelle das gleiche jetzt auch rüber
in eine abstellkammer aber er ist auch
nicht laut also ich könnte auch in der
küche stehen lassen so dass ich hier
gleich wieder platz ab das haus gehört
gepumpt hat war übrigens der backofen da
hat nämlich gerade abgepumpt weil ich da
was gedämpft habe okay hier mache ich
jetzt mal acht stunden neun stunden ich
habe es ein bisschen dicker gelassen 50
grad
fertig okay ich mache das hier noch ein
bisschen obst morgen mache ich erst
gemüse dann habe ich einfach schön
separat auch und dann zeige ich ihnen
noch weitere dinge die ihr trocknung
fühlt
[Musik]
ich liebe meine kräuter hier draußen im
hochbeet und gerade im sommer komme ich
dann echt immer gerne raus luxe hier
ganz frisch im winter ist es kräuterhof
wird natürlich ein bisschen zugefroren
und es gibt wenige die einfach
überwintern
das heißt ich kann mich jetzt hier im
sommer schön aufs glück jetzt wächst
auch alles gut nach kant anderen und
dadurch intensiviert sich natürlich auch
das aroma das heißt ich habe dann
einfach keinen feuchtigkeitsgehalt mehr
in den kräutern und habe schön die
getrockneten kräuter mit dem vollen
intensiven aroma ich habe jetzt ein
bisschen beck bohnenkraut fenzl und
minze hier nehme ich noch ein bisschen
magie zweck sowieso ganz stark hier
und dann habe ich meinen zorn
gott die kräuter müssen jetzt im prinzip
nur gewaschen werden und dann können sie
auch schon trocknen entweder macht ihr
es so wie meine mama sie breiteten ein
großes tuch aus am besten immer auf dem
esstisch aber dann liegt es dort eben
auch so etwa eine woche lang bis die
kräuter ganz trocken sind oder ihr
trocknet sie im der automaten so mache
ich
schneider jetzt noch die kräuter etwas
trocken
so habe ich nämlich noch die
restfeuchtigkeit direkt weg und dann
kann ich hier auf mehreren ebenen
einfach die kräuter deren oder wie
gesagt auf einem geschirrtuch oder zum
beispiel auf einem großen küchentuch als
auf so einer tischdecke einfach mehrere
tage trocknen nach dass ich jetzt schon
gut das riecht super und da muss ich
ganz ehrlich sagen die lege ich auch so
wissel übereinander auf eine komplette
ebene
das trocknet dann trotzdem gut durch
[Musik]
ja so sieht es dann bei mir
typischerweise aus wenig fehlt daher und
macht wirklich fast wöchentlich also es
gibt auch mal eine woche wo ich gar
nicht gedacht habe aber dann habe ich
wieder so ein
der schwung und der was das zeug hält
gerade jetzt im sommer wächst ja auch
vieles bei uns im garten
ich hab das ist jetzt meine vorräte vom
letzten jahr sogar noch meine kräuter
vorräte
da habe ich zum beispiel meinen salbei
gehört hier vorne habe ich sellerie
da habe ich ein knollensellerie bei mir
im hochbeet hab dann das grün gedauert
und habe aber auch die sellerieknolle
gedauert
das heißt ich habe hier den sellerie in
würfel geschnitten und dann einfach
gedauert habe jetzt hier einfach immer
schön für suppen oder für gerichte meine
gewürze fenzl habe ich hier wenn er
nicht den kompletten fenzl vom hochbett
auffrisst und hier habe ich einfach
verschiedene sorten wie zum beispiel
zitronenverbene das heißt ich habe ja
auch meine grundlagen zum kochen aber
auch zum genießen denn daraus mache ich
auch gerne täter zitronenverbene ist
mega lecker und durchs darin mache ich
die lebensmittel nicht nur haltbarer
sondern man internet so wird auch den
geschmack weil einfach das wasser
entzogen wird und ich hab dann den
vollen geschmack mit sogar ganz wenig
volumen nur schön komprimiert mit diesem
wilden haufen hier handelt sich es ums
thema einfrieren
denn auch das einfrieren ist eine gute
methode um lebensmittel auf vorrat immer
dazu haben das setzt natürlich voraus
dass man einen gefrierschrank hat wir
hatten früher auch nur so ein kleines
gefrierfach und da musste ich halt immer
gucken was überhaupt rein passt war
immer nur eine begrenzte menge
jetzt haben wir einen gefrierschrank mit
schiebern ich muss trotzdem sagen meine
mama hat immer noch den größeren
gefrierschrank und ich halte nicht
deswegen ich habe aber auch ganz gerne
den vorrat dort im überblick und einfach
immer nicht zu viel lebensmittel könnt
ihr im gefrierschrank bis zu ein jahr
bevorraten
und da gibt es einfach viele dinge die
man auf vorrat haben kann und manche
dinge die sollte man nicht einfrieren
also ich arbeite mich mal von hier nach
da was er immer ganz gut einfrieren
könnt ist fleisch da habe ich zum einen
immer hackfleisch dar weil ich einfach
fleisch um stück kaufen
es geht alles durch einen fleischwolf
ich wacom ihre es dann das heißt ich
pack's hier in kleine behälter in kleine
beutel drücken
und warum ihr so bekommt zum einen
keinen gefrierbrand ist fest
verschlossen und wenn ich es dann
aufbauen möchte geht auch super schnell
weil das hackfleisch wirklich schön
flach ist und nicht als grosse kugel
es gibt auch viele die hackfleisch
abgepackt kaufen ihnen diesen
kunststoffverpackungen und da ist ganz
viel luft drin und wenn ihr es so
einfach einfriert ist es auftauen viel
viel mühsamer weil es eben viel länger
dauert also wirklich hackfleisch schön
flach einfrieren
dann habe ich auch immer ganz gerne
hähnchen zum beispiel vakuumiert und
eingefroren oder beispielsweise auch
lars und moritz lieblings würstchen die
werden auch einfach wako metern
eingefroren und so entsteht dann eben
auch im gefrierfach kein gefrierbrand
was ihr auch nur wunderbar einbringen
könnte sind kräuter ich habe zum
beispiel gerne schnittlauch und
petersilie auf vorrat
ich schneide dann vorher klein habe sie
in den dosen drin und wenn ich dann
brauche kann man es schön nach haus
nehmen ihr seht es klebt dann auch nicht
zusammen
es gibt heute die lassen sich nicht so
gut einfrieren basilikum zum beispiel
verliert einfach total an geschmack aber
jetzt grad i 2 kräuter also schnittlauch
und petersilie habe ich eigentlich immer
gewusst wenn wir schon beim würzen sind
ihr könnt auch immer gut zitronen und
orangenschalen einfrieren
ich kauf mir meist bio zitronen bei
denen man die schale auch verzehren kann
und manchmal brauche ich aber keine
zitronenschale und dann reibe ich die
vorher einfach ab kann sie hier einen
gefäß geben und eins werden und habe
dann eben auch immer zitronenschale auf
vorrat da was man auch wunderbar
einfrieren kann ist gebäck also zum
einen droht natürlich immer schön
verpackt haben wir gerne fladenbrot da
und zum anderen könnt ihr auch anderes
gebäck 13 die berliner oder kuchen und
müsste dann einfach nur noch bei
raumtemperatur auftauen lassen oder eben
ganz kurz in der mikrowelle sowas könnte
immer gut einfrieren vor allem wenn ihr
mal zu viel von omas gehabt und habe
dann eben auch im gefrierfach einfach da
hier habe ich noch tomatenmark das kaufe
ich immer gerne in so einer großen
verpackung wobei es für türkische
verhältnisse eine kleine dreitages
verpackung ist also eine große türkische
verpackung ist dann so 5 liter
tomatenmark und ich persönlich
ich liebe tomatenmark aber ich benutze
setzen nicht jeden tag das heißt ich
habe schon die erfahrung gemacht wenn
ich so ein glas habe und ich benutze es
eine weile nicht fängt natürlich an zu
schimmeln im kühlschrank
jetzt könnt ihr folgendes tun entweder
glättet ihr jetzt hier die oberfläche
schüttet öl darüber also wieder einlegen
so dass einfach kein sauerstoff an die
oberfläche kommt könnt ihr machen dann
ist es wirklich mehrere wochen haltbar
im kühlschrank
nur muss man immer sauber vorgehen weil
gerade hier diese länder die man da hat
die da nicht mit öl bedeckt sind können
dann anfangen zu schimmeln
oder er macht einfach so wie ich ihr
nehmt eiswürfel behälter mit deckel
streicht hier das tomatenmark rhein
zieht schön glatt match aber und dann
wird abgedeckt und eingefroren und dann
können dir einfach wenn ihr bisschen
tomatenmark braucht das hier schön raus
drücken und habe gleich eine schöne
kleine portionen und so habe ich das
jetzt aufgemacht habe hier tomatenmark
und paprika marc happe schön im vorrat
und direkt schon vor portioniert und
wenn ihr keine eiswürfel form mit decke
ab nimmt ihr einfach einige trier tüte
für das tomatenmark davids dann
eingeführt
dann ganz wichtig um schlagen hier oben
oder abonnieren könnt ihr auch machen
es gibt ja auch diese behälter dieses
subtypen dann könnt ihr auch oben zu
machen und jetzt wieder schön glatt
machen mit einer tankkarte kann man das
hier dann so einteilen und dann habt ihr
auch einzelportionen die ihr dann nach
dem einfrieren einfach auftragen können
gemüse lässt sich natürlich auch super
einfrieren da habe ich zum einen selbst
ein gefrorenes gemüse wird wohnen oder
hier mangold von einem hochbeet oder ich
habe auch immer gemüse da wie zum
beispiel gefrorene erbsen
ich kaufe ich dann habt ihr noch ein
fach für gemüse und dann ist da einfach
alles immer drin was habe ich noch hier
habe ich noch früchte
das hier sind als gekaufte früchte aber
ihr könnt natürlich auch wenn gerade
früchte saison ist und jetzt viele
erdbeeren heidelbeeren himbeeren da
einfach verpacken entweder auch wacom
ihren oder in luftig das gefäß packen
und einfrieren und was viele nicht
wissen
ihr könnt bananen einfrieren und diese
bananen waren bevor ich sie eingefroren
habe gelb sie waren zwar schon schön
reif also so leicht braunen flecken die
habe ich dann einfach so eingefroren und
so habe ich immer schöne kalte bananen
da die schale wird zwar hässlich
brauchen aber im innern ist jetzt noch
schön gelb also nicht nicht brauchen
und die kann ich jetzt benutzen und
schälen um zum beispiel smoothies zu
machen oder um ein eis herzustellen
und dann habe ich einfach schon direkt
die kalte obstsorte mit dabei braucht
keine eiswürfel und ab sozusagen dann
keine verwässerung des geschmacks ich
habe einfach die kalte banane und die
sorgt daneben dafür dass es getränk oder
das eis schön kalt ist ihr könnt ja auch
gerne vorher in scheiben schneiden und
schälen und dann einfrieren das geht
auch um genau so könnt ihr auch irgendwo
oder kurkuma immer bevorraten im
gefrierfach
ihr könnt chilis ganz gut einfrieren die
kann man dann auch super kleine reiben
wenn sie gefroren sind
ihr könnt hefe immer super einfrieren
also ich friere die entweder als hefe
würfel 1 oder als selbst gezüchtete hefe
da gibt es auch schon ein video wo ich
dann auch portionsweise ausdrücken kann
käse könnt ihr auch super einfrieren und
gerade wenn ihr hier so einen großen
käse hat so einen käse der hat 800 gramm
abtropfgewicht das heißt es sind glaube
ich vier oder viereinhalb rädchen käse
drin und es ist mir jetzt auch nicht
immer auf einmal auf und wenn ich da mal
was übrig habt nämlich den einfach raus
ist kompletter rädchen für pax luftdicht
und dann wird eingefroren
man muss dazu sagen dass vierten käse
oder generell milchprodukte wenn sie
eingefroren werden gruselig schmecken
können das heißt ich bin aus dem käse
dann wirklich nur noch zum überbacken
oder gratinieren oder für in den tus zum
beispiel ein
auch mit schnittkäse funktion
das prima aber parmesan oder grappa
dabei könnt ihr zum beispiel super
einfrieren und dann einfach hobeln und
über die pasta gerichte trotzdem noch
verwenden was ich nicht einfriere ist
zum beispiel saure sahne oder schmand
die habe ich einfach im kühlschrank
immer sahne kann man anscheinend auch
wunderbar einfrieren probiert habe ich
noch nicht wie gesagt milchprodukte
können christlich werden
aber was sie auch gut einfrieren können
ist butter das heißt wenn ihr mal beim
angebot habt oder wenn ihr zu viel
butter habt einfach nur einfrieren und
fordern benutzen wieder auftauen lassen
funktioniert super für heute gebäck für
urteil für butter krems gehabt da
wirklich dann immer was da wenn wir beim
thema backen sind und wenig motiv torten
mache habe ich auch immer ganz gerne mal
garage übrig und ghanas kann man auch
einfrieren
also die habe ich jetzt hier noch übrig
gehabt ich habe weiße und dunkle und
vollmilch danach übrig früher sie
einfach ein
und bevor ich sie benutze wird es
einfach aufgetaut und ich kann sie noch
mal kurz erwärmen damit sie eben wieder
schön geschmeidig ist und dann ganz
normal weiter verwenden
genauso können wir es mit eiern machen
eier kann man auch gut einfrieren
danach halt muss man sehr komplett
durchgegart essen
man darf sie nicht mit der schale
einfrieren weil sie eben platzt das soll
aber vielleicht dazu sagen aber gerade
wenn ihr ei geld übrig habt oder eiweiß
übrig habt weil er zum beispiel nur die
andere komponente gebraucht habt könnte
es in dem gefäß geben und einfrieren und
dann einfach beim backen benutzen
und da kann man sich ganz gut merken vor
allem wenn man nicht mehr weiß wie viele
eigelb oder wie viel eiweiß in der
schale sind kann man sich einfach das
gewicht des ice ein bisschen ausrechnen
und zwar hatten einer größe m immer etwa
15 km eigelb und 35 gramm eiweiß und so
passt seinen der regel general immer so
dazu was man nicht so gut einfrieren
kann ist blattsalat weil blattsalat nach
dem gefrieren natürlich einfach matschig
wird unser feld die einzige ausnahme ist
im prinzip spinat oder mangold denn
spinat oder mangold wird meist sowieso
gekocht verzehrt das heißt spinat könnt
ihr entweder kurz vor kochen also
blanchieren und einfrieren oder eben
auch schon gefroren kaufen arbeitsplatz
salade chicorée eisbergsalat kopfsalat
da funktioniert hat nicht so gut und was
man auch nicht
frieren sollte sind wasserreiche obst
und gemüsesorten als es so was wie
orangen gurken wassermelone
das wird einfach alles sehr matschig was
ihr aber machen könnt ist ihr könnt den
saft der orangen zum beispiel auspressen
und dann einfach den eiswürfel formen
geben einfrieren und habe dann einfach
schön kühl eiswürfel um zum beispiel ein
getränk herunterzukühlen
was man da auch ganz gut einfrieren kann
sind teile wie zum beispiel hefeteig
gebäck wie pizza oder auch baguette
brötchen die kann man sich vor backen
oder auch roh einfrieren und dann
einfach nach dem einfrieren in einem
backofen schieben oder auch frittieren
donuts zum beispiel was ja auch gut
einbringen könnte ist zum beispiel
blätterteig den ständig auch ganz gerne
selber her oder ich kaufe auch mal im
blätterteig und habt ihr dann auch
einfach im vorrat was wirklich niemals
never er war in den kühlschrank und auch
nicht in den gefrierschrank darf sind
kartoffeln
die werden nämlich ich weiß nicht
welches euch mal passiert dass
kartoffeln zu kalt gelagert wurden
und die werden einfach ganz süß wenn sie
eingefroren werden oder auch gekühlt
werden und werden auch relativ matschig
also irgendwie verwandelt sich die
stärke in zucker um sie schmecken
komplett süß und eben gar nicht mehr so
nach kartoffeln also das solltet ihr auf
jeden fall vermeiden was ihr auch ganz
gut mit obst und gemüse resten machen
könnt ist dass ihr obst und gemüsereste
direkt in kleine tüten abfüllt oder in
kleine behälter können sie einfrieren
und dann habt ihr immer direkt nismo
vibrationen die ihr einfach nur noch
nixon ist für jeden tag also da kann man
auch so ein bisschen mut machen so ein
bisschen essens vorbereitung einfach die
ananas schneiden mango schneiden obst
und gemüse dazu einfrieren in tüten und
dann habt ihr jeden tag eine schöne
portion motiv eine weitere methode dinge
oder lebensmittel haltbarer zu machen
ist das wrack um ihren denn beim bakom
ihren wird einfach der sauerstoff also
die luft entzogen und die lebensmittel
sind länger haltbar ganz gut ist es
sogar wenn man das bakom ihren und das
einfrieren kombiniert so könnt ihr zum
beispiel fleisch was normalerweise ein
jahr ungefähr haltbar wäre im
gefrierschrank durch das wacom ihren
aufs doppelte haltbar machen also die
zwei kombiniert sind echt gut denn durch
das vakuum entsteht einfach kein gefühl
frost auf den lebensmitteln also ihr
könnt zum beispiel fleisch hack um ihren
uns an den kühlschrank legen damit es
länger haltbar ist
ihr könnt so wie hier
maronen einkochen und wacom ihren ihr
könnt aber auch offenes gebäck offenen
typen mit chips oder salzbrezeln ich
weiß bei vielen bleiben die nicht offen
und es bleibt einfach nicht mehr übrig
denn wenn sie aber geöffnet sind sie
leer
aber wenn ihr sie geöffnet habt und ihr
sagt ihr wollt sie in der
originalverpackung aufbewahrt
könnt ihr die auch wieder back um ihren
und die liste entziehen ihr könnt aber
auch cremes ich habe hier zum beispiel
so eine frischkäse paprika creme gemacht
die jetzt hier ein gefüllt das ist wie
so eine creme vom türken oder von
griechen und die kann ich jetzt auch
warum ihn und die luft entziehen oder
ich kann auch kaffee wieder wachsen
wir benutzen immer kaffeebohnen und bei
kaffee bohnen ist es zum beispiel so da
haben die typen hier wie so eine art
ventil
denn bei café bohn ist ganz wichtig beim
argument dass nicht zu viel war also
nicht zu viel werbung gemacht wird dass
nicht zu viel luft raus gezogen wird und
somit das aroma verschwindet also sorgt
jedes ventil dann dafür dass doch noch
so ein bisserl zirkulation da ist jetzt
könnt ihr zum einen mit einem vakuum ihr
gerät arbeiten so wie ich sagt unter der
kaffeemaschine habe ich so eine
elektrische vakuumpumpe unternehmens ein
manuelles gerät da gibt es spezielle
typen dafür das heißt ihr habt so einem
zip behälter setzt hier an und zieht die
luft raus und so könnt ihr zum beispiel
auch salami obst gemüse wacom ihren und
das ganze wirklich länger im kühlschrank
haltbar machen oder wie gesagt wenn ihr
einmal komik gerät habt könnt ihr auch
so flache gläser reinstellen
es gibt auch einen schlauch da könnt ihr
auch große behälter wacom ihren oder wie
gesagt solche behälter solche typen
frieda verschließen
ich habe ich meine wako mehr schublade
und wie gesagt habe ich hier den schlaf
so kann ich wirklich auch große behälter
anschließen und warum ihren ohne dass
ich sie hier einstellen muss fleisch
komme ich ganz gerne zum einen weil es
länger haltbar ist aber zum anderen auch
zur aroma bildung ich kann jetzt hier
nämlich auch rosmarin dazu geben
ein bisschen butter dazugeben als ich
kenne im prinzip den geschmack denn ich
möchte hiermit reingeben in kleinster
menge denn durch zwei kopien entsteht
ein unterdruck und das aroma zieht
sofort ins fleisch ein
genauso bei obstsalat wenn ihr zum
beispiel obst salat zubereiten wollte
alles in den behälter geben hier kurz
weg um ihren und dunlop
ob das auch so richtig also wird kochen
aber es kocht nicht aber das aroma zieht
sofort ein also wenn ihr dann ein
bisschen man in zb dran gift ist sofort
eingezogen und ihm ist dinge und
lebensmittel einfach nicht lange
marinieren lassen sondern es geht in
sekunden schneller
wie gesagt kann ich jetzt hier noch die
creme backum ihren dienst aber auch
länger haltbar ist dann nicht mehr
anfällig
kommt jetzt ist es ganz fest so
[Musik]
das einkaufen ist auch eine altbewährte
methode um lebensmittel länger haltbar
zu machen und um sie zu konservieren
so könnt ihr zum beispiel früchte zu
marmelade gelee oder kompott verarbeiten
ihr könnt saucen herstellen suppen ein
kochen oder auch ganze gerichte wie
chili con carne oder eine polonaise
einkochen
ich habe hier verschiedene soßen und so
könnt ihr euch lebensmittel wirklich
schön einkochen
ich zeige euch jetzt nicht genau wie
denn da gibt's ja schon einige rezepte
auf meinem kanal wichtig ist im prinzip
nur dass er gläser verwendet die dann
sterilisiert werden also gesäubert
werden die könnt ihr entweder in wasser
aufkochen
im backofen sterilisieren in der
mikrowelle oder in dampfgarer damit
einfach keine keime ins innere gelangen
und sich vermehren können und dann könnt
ihr die saucen kochen die suppen die
marmelade heißt ein film verschließen
und dadurch gelangen dann eben auch
keine keime ins innere
ihr könnt dann eben schön das gab und
ein füllen verschließen und so habt ihr
es eben schön konserviert und das ist
mehrere monate haltbar zucker lieben
jahr fast alle und zucker ist auch wie
salz ein konservierungsmittel und wird
eben auch zu konservieren von
lebensmitteln eingesetzt
das ganze nennt sich dann kann dir und
ihr kennt vielleicht kandierten ingwer
ihr kennt aber auch vielleicht orangeat
und zitronat da wird nämlich einfach
durch zucker durch eine zuckerlösung die
dann über die früchte gegossen wird wird
der wassergehalt rausgezogen wir sind
einfach auf modische prozesse und
dadurch werden die lebensmittel eben
auch länger haltbar der zuckergehalt
steigt dann in den früchten auf 70% an
mindestens und ja sie halten eben dann
eigentlich fast ewig irgendwann muss ich
sagen mag ich kann dir ganz gerne weil
irgendwas seine schärfe hat und dann
durch die süße einfach richtig gut
schmeckt ich selbst kann die hre nicht
weil ich denke mir halt bevor ich jetzt
die orangen und zitronen kann die hre
kann ich sie auch die rektoren hab da
einfach keinen zucker mit dabei und vor
allem könnt ihr kandierte früchte kann
man wahrscheinlich auch gut mal was für
wasser auf das verarbeiten oder zur
verpachtung verarbeiten
aber im prinzip bringt einfach noch mal
zucker rein und ich glaube zucker hat
sowieso jeder so ein bisschen im
überfluss als ich denke früher war das
eine ganz gute methode um früchte eben
länger haltbar zu machen
heute würde ich jetzt eher sagen braucht
man es vielleicht nicht unbedingt für
lebkuchen
ist es vielleicht ganz wichtig dass man
orangeat und zitronat nimmt aber
ansonsten muss ich persönlich für mich
sagen so hefegebäck mag ich nicht mit
orangeat und zitronat aber kandierten
inga den nazis schon mal ganz gerne oder
kandierte rosenblätter oder
blütenblätter die kann man auch ganz gut
machen die kann man wirklich super
haltbar machen habe ich auch schon mal
ausprobiert und da finde ich machen wir
das denn weil man sie für die deko
benutzen kann und die eben nicht gar
nicht halten würden
das waren jetzt meine zehn tipps zur
konservierung und zur haltbarmachung von
lebensmitteln
natürlich sollte immer einen gesunden
fahrrad zu hause haben damit ihr eben
spontan kochen und backen könnt nicht
einkaufen gehen müsst und eben nicht in
solln notstand kommt dass ihr eben
nichts zu hause habt außerdem ist es
auch ganz gut für eure kasse denn ihr
könnt gezielter einkaufen kauft nicht so
viel aber auch nicht zu wenig was er im
vorratsschrank oder in einem vorratsraum
haben solltet kann ich euch ganz genau
nicht sagen denn das ist ja auch
personenbezogen manche essen lieber
nudeln haben wir gemerkt andere lieber
kartoffeln oder reis manche verzichten
ganz auf kohlenhydrate und ernähren sich
lieber ausschließlich von gemüse und
obst
was sie aber immer wissen solltet ist
egal wie groß der vorratsschrank ist
oder der vorratsraum halten einen
überblick über vorräte
wir haben hier unseren vorratsschrank
drüben haben bei unseren vorratsraum
aber darf auch als schrank hier ist
sozusagen unser back & koch
vorratsschrank hierfür die videos oder
auch wenn wir mit dem team hier
zusammenkommen
und ich habe hier oben zum beispiel so
ein bisschen trockene produkte wie
zucker und mehl stärke salz verschiedene
mehlsorten und wichtig ist dass wir beim
einkaufen darauf achtet die alten
lebensmittel rutschen nach vorne und die
neu eingekauften kommen nach hinten so
kann zum einen nichts verderben und ihr
behaltet einfach den überblick dann ist
auch noch wichtig im vorratsschrank
macht keine experimente das heißt kauft
nur dinge auf vorrat die ihr wirklich
verzerrt wenn ihr zum beispiel absolut
keine haferflocken ist müsst ihr auch
keine haare flocken auf vorrat da haben
die könnt ihr mal so ausprobieren so ein
päckchen ausprobieren aber wie gesagt
auf vorrat hat man wirklich nur was man
ständig und in großen mengen eben auch
konsumiert also hier oben habe ich hier
auf sicht
sozusagen diese vorräte habe ich jetzt
auch kein schieber weil ich eben alles
in einer reihe hintereinander habe und
hier unten habe ich dann noch schieber
da habe ich dann alles ganz
übersichtlich drin wie zum beispiel
milch oder hier habe ich meinen
kokosfett mit dabei hier unten habe ich
sowie süße schublade mit obst konserven
marmeladen oder schokoladencreme und
hier links er so das herzhafte wie
oliven verschiedene andere öle dosen
konserven eingemachtes und hier unten
noch trockene vorräte wie nudeln reis
bulgur couscous oder kaffee also ich
hoffe euch hat dieses video gefallen und
ihr habt die ein oder anderen tipps und
tricks mitgenommen zur bevorratung und
zum haltbarmachen von gewissen
lebensmitteln zwar kann es sein dass
sich liste ich wünsche euch viel spaß
beim nachmachen schreibt mir gerne eure
tipps und tricks auch in die kommentare
und wir sehen uns wieder das nächste mal
dann schreibt auch gerne wenn ihr
weitere videos dieser art sehen möchtet
den vorratsschrank zum beispiel oder den
vorratsraum oder noch weitere tipps und
tricks rund um das darin schreibt mir
einfach
haben wir mehr
[Musik]